Me escuchas con frecuencia utilizar la palabra
abstracto y por esta razón decidí hacer
una definición o más bien, dar la intuición
de qué es esto de lo abstracto.
Abstracto puede ser un adjetivo, como decir
una idea abstracta,
también puedes tener arte abstracto...
Abstracto también puede ser un verbo,
como abstraer ideas, abstraer algo y también puede
ser utilizado como un pronombre,
por ejemplo, me viene a la mente en el ambiente científico, los textos que escriben los científicos,
tienen un resumen que suele llamarse "Abstract".
Pero independientemente del contexto en el
que escuchemos esta palabra, abstracto, nos
referimos a esta noción de lo esencial
que tiene un objeto del mundo real, no importa
que lo usemos como pronombre, como verbo,
como adjetivo, así que por aquí tenemos
nuestro mundo real.
Sí, aquí está el mundo real y por este
lado tenemos las ideas y los conceptos...
La idea general detrás de lo abstracto es
tomar ese objeto fuera del mundo real
y llevarlo hacia el plano de las ideas y los conceptos.
Y probablemente para mí, una de las formas de hacer más tangible esto de lo abstracto y...
pero estoy diciendo una contradicción,
¿cómo hacer algo tangible de lo abstracto?
Me gusta pensar en las figuras geométricas,
por ejemplo, si yo te dijera, muéstrame un cubo,
pues podrías pensar en esta nave extraterrestre
Borg o tal vez te refieras a un par de dados,
sí, a un par de dados...
déjame dibujarlos aquí.
Si estamos buscando cubos podemos pensar en
dados y que se ven más o menos como esto,
también podrías pensar en el cubo de Rubik,
también es probable que en tu casa
tengas una caja, que es un cubo.
Pero en tu mente tienes ya una idea de lo que es un cubo. Tú sabes lo que es un cubo cuando ves uno.
Pero la idea general es como destilar el concepto,
de qué es un cubo,
todas estas cosas son muy distintas, éste que está aquí pues es un objeto de plástico que puedo poner
en mi mano, éste que está acá, este...
pues si pensamos tiene las puntas un poco achatadas,
ésta de acá pues es una gran nave extraterrestre Borg, claro, es una cosa ficticia pero ahí está,
pero todos ellos tienen un carácter de cubo,
de los fundamentos de la geometría.
Y si tenemos una definición en geometría
de qué es un cubo y es un objeto,
como éste que está aquí en el que cada uno de sus lados tiene la misma longitud.
Si este lado fuera 1, pues éste también será 1 y el otro 1,
aunque no tiene que ser un número, cualquiera que sea la longitud de esta dimensión,
será la longitud de esta otra dimensión,
igual que la longitud de esta otra dimensión.
Bueno, no voy a intentar dar aquí la definición exactamente geométrica de que es un cubo,
pero tenemos una idea de lo que es un cubo.
y en el mundo real, no hay nada que sea
exactamente un cubo,
o sea, si yo tomara este objeto y lo midiera con cuidado, tal vez no serían exactamente igual los lados,
pero en nuestra idea abstracta de qué es un cubo, éste lado es exactamente igual a éste,
igual a éste y a éste también, a cualquiera de ellos.
Así que podemos decir que a partir de los objetos del mundo real...
ah bueno, aunque en este caso sean futuristas,
nos vamos a la idea, a la idea general que
está detrás de esto.
Y también es probable que hayas escuchado
la palabra abstracto en el ambiente del arte,
arte abstracto.
Y aquí tenemos un ejemplo.
Y también si nos remitimos al diccionario,
va a entontrar muchas definiciones, pero todas
se refieren a lo mismo, una de estas definiciones
puede decir, el arte abstracto
no trata de reflejar la realidad,
a diferenciad el arte renacentista
donde se retrataba la realidad con mucho detalle.
Muchas veces el arte abstracto ni siquiera trata de representar algo que corresponde a la realidad,
a veces es una expresión digamos cruda de la realidad o simplemente una expresión de colores y texturas...
Éste que tenemos aquí es de Jackson Pollock, espero estar pronunciando bien los nombres,
y este ejemplo lo tomé del historiador arte,
Aron Stevens, en este ejemplo, Jackson Pollock no está
retratando ni un perro, ni un caballo, ningún
objeto conocido por nosotros
y ni siquiera sabemos si esto corresponde a la realidad.
Y el concepto abstracción no nada más se refiere a los objetos geométricos o al arte,
está inmerso en nuestra vida diaria, simplemente al utilizar palabras o símbolos para referirnos a algo,
estamos haciendo referencia de una manera abstracta a esos objetos de nuestra vida diaria.
Por ejemplo, si yo utilizo la palabra perro,
pero observemos, es simplemente un conjunto
de símbolos que nos remiten a una figura
como ésta, que es un animalito que tienen
cuatro patas y tiene unas orejas suavecitas
y que nos gusta acariciar y también decimos
que es el mejor amigo del hombre, pero en
el mundo real, hay hasta grandes diferencias
entre los mismos perros, es una variedad de
animales, no es lo mismo un gran danés que
por ejemplo, un poodle pequeñín, pero reconocemos
la esencia, la esencia de lo que hace este
concepto y podemos abstraer lo que es un perro
y también utilizamos estos símbolos para
representar el concepto de un perro.
Pero ahora quiero pensar en un número, por ejemplo si escribo el número 5 pues es algo tan familiar a nosotros,
aparentemente es un objeto concreto
y simplemente es una cantidad
que yo podría representar de diversas maneras eh...
como ésta o como un cinco en romano
o también puedo representarlo de esta
manera y en todos los casos,
todos estos símbolos y representaciones se refieren a una cantidad de cinco cosas.
Y por ejemplo, si yo le pregunto a alguien, muéstrame un cinco, es probable que seleccione esta representación
a este símbolo, pero es una idea sumamente abstracta.
Con suerte, ya tenemos una idea de lo que significa abstracto y a falta de otra palabra,
pues solo puedo decir que es una idea abstracta.